Today, I'm going to be discussing a clinical trial evaluating iberdomyte versus lenandromyte
in the post-transplant maintenance setting that Dr. Zander alluded to. Here are my disclosures.
So just taking a step back, the goal of myeloma therapy for all transplant-eligible and
ineligible patients is to try and capitalize on this initial opportunity to try and achieve the
best possible or deepest possible response, utilizing the most effective induction regimen
and trying to consolidate the response with transplant if feasible, and then offering
very well-tolerated and effective maintenance strategies to try and prolong this PFS1 as much
as possible. So recognizing that PFS1 is important and correlates to overall survival is important.
So this figure kind of illustrates the depth of response,
achieved at each level of therapy with induction, transplant, and then how maintenance therapy
adds to delaying relapse in multiple myeloma, and this is so important as we try to
find a cure for myeloma as a community. So just going back further in history as to how
len maintenance became the center of care, so Dr. McCarthy's team kind of evaluated
len maintenance versus observation in a large meta-analysis with 1,200 patients,
and what the study showed was that len maintenance and PFS1 are very similar.
The study showed was a dramatic improvement in PFS and OS in patients with len maintenance as
compared to observation. The next question that was important was trying to determine if there's
fixed duration therapy or treatment under progression was better, and this question
was tried to answer by the determination trial in the IFM 2009 study, and what we learned was that
treatment under disease progression was associated with a better PFS as compared to observation.
We also learned with different studies that len maintenance alone might not be adequate for the
high-risk or ultra-high-risk patients, so bottom line, len is the current center of care maintenance
regimen that is recommended. Continuing with maintenance therapy until disease progression
is the way to go, especially for high-risk patients, and PFS and OS unfortunately still
remain inferior in the ultra-high-risk or high-risk patients with len maintenance alone as compared to
standard-risk patients. So that's why there are several combination agents that are being
evaluated in the high-risk patients like I alluded to in my talk yesterday. But we all know we've all
had patients that have been on len maintenance indefinitely, and the challenges that our patients
face in terms of the side-effect profile of len with diarrhea, cytopenias, fatigue, risk of thromboembolism, long-term risk of second primary care, and post-diagnostic treatment.
And thus, there is a need to find maybe a better tolerated and more effective, if possible, maintenance agent for these patients.
So here's a blurb about iberdomide. I think Dr. Zandra already covered this. It's a
new cell mod agent, cerebron E3 ligase modulating agent that is shown to have superior potency
than len and may provide additional therapeutic benefit. So like Dr. Zandra alluded to, iberdomide
binds to cerebron with a much higher binding affinity, causes deeper degradation of the
icros and aloes, and has been shown to enhance myeloma cell killing and immune,
stronger immune activation of T cells and NK cells as compared to the imids.
Unlike len, iber is actually administered as a single enantiomer in the S-isomer form,
which is maintained in vivo. And that might be the reason, or it can help to avoid certain
side effects like sedation and fatigue that are attributed to the R-isomer.
And based on the data coming out from the CC220 Phase 1, Phase 2 trial evaluating iber's safety
and efficacy in relapsed or factory patients, I think there is enough data justifying the use of
this agent in earlier lines of treatment and especially in the maintenance setting.
So this is a key trial, the EMN26, a Phase 2 multi-cohort study that is evaluating iberdomide
at different dose levels in newly diagnosed myeloma patients that have achieved at least
a PR with triplet or quadruplet induction therapy and can be enrolled for up to four months after
transplant. The primary endpoint of the study was improvement in response within six months.
And the second key secondary endpoints were rates of MRD conversion from positive to negative,
PFS, and then the safety profile. Here's the baseline characteristics of the trial.
What I would like to highlight is that in the 0.75 milligram cohort of iberdomide,
higher frequency of patients received quadruplet induction with either data VTD or data
VRD as compared to the other dose cohorts. And they also received consolidation therapy more
frequently than the other dose cohorts. So moving on to results, the trial didn't
meet its primary endpoint of response improvement within six months. And we saw basically 36% all
the way up to 59% response improvement within six months. And that's a null hypothesis of response
improvement of less than or equal to 20% was rejected. And in the 0.75 milligram cohort of
iberdomide, 60% of the patients achieved MRD negative status at any time point. And the
rates of conversion of MRD from positive to negative increased over time with this study.
The two-year PFS in the 0.75 milligram cohort was 92%.
In terms of adverse events, the major hematologic adverse event that was noted was neutropenia.
In grade three, grade four, neutropenia was seen in about 48% of the patients in the 0.75 milligram cohort.
No grade three or four anemia or thrombocytopenia were reported. And in the 0.75 milligram cohort,
apart from infections, very few other non-hematologic grade three, grade four adverse
events were noted. So it definitely has a more manageable safety profile. And thus based on these
results, the 0.75 milligram dose of iberdomide was selected to be evaluated as a maintenance agent in
this last phase three multicenter randomized control trial, which is currently ongoing,
evaluating head-to-head iberdomide maintenance against revlimid maintenance in newly diagnosed
myeloma patients post-transplant. The primary endpoint was PFS and
secondary endpoints of OS and MRD. The study is sort of ongoing and hoping to
we get some more updates about this study in this upcoming ASHRAE meeting. And thus I would like to
conclude that iberdomide maintenance led to response improvement over time in patients with
newly diagnosed myeloma post-induction and transplant, and it compared favorably with
len maintenance. Iber actually demonstrated 46 to 72% response improvement at cycle 12 as compared
to 31% that was noted with len maintenance in the prior EMN2 study. Promising rates of MRD conversion
were reported with iberdomide maintenance and iber showed a manageable safety profile with very few
grade three grade four non-hematologic adverse events that were reported. And the 0.75 milligram
dose of iberdomide is now being compared head to head with revlimid in the large phase three
Excalibur maintenance trial. Hopefully we get a readout soon at this ASH. With that,
I would like to thank my Emory Myeloma Group and happy to take questions.